oh my god oh my god i'm intimidating
oh my god my understanding is that you
are a professional card thrower
yes so there you go
damn i want to see what this looks like
channel is no way his way
[Applause]
these are normal cards these are normal
standard pack playing cards
today we have a special treat for you
nick from the channel no way asway is
here
to show us some really impressive card
throwing like the deadly
cards growing fruit vegetables foam core
he's going to show us just
how dangerous a pack of cards can be in
the right hands they come out with some
some speed man
what i'll probably be teaching you guys
today is obviously how to throw them
normal yeah we can normally do with this
one
as you could whoa you're going to place
the rubber band
and the index finger in the thumb
release the card you're going to take
the pivot part
this is going to be that little logo
right there place it and you're going to
clamp down pinch it the rubber band and
the card
run in the back pull back just like a
slingshot and then let go
wow everybody can do it try to
lower his mind well i need to figure out
exactly how big a car hit that
all right 88 62 by 88 all right
hi i'm sam what's up 60 by 88.
nick we show brandon hey
what is that
hey wren
i already know how to throw cards
i just don't have any aim okay this is
this is far too short to put my mouth
why do i walk into this stuff man
oh you hit it though
man just feeling the impact on my hands
that's nerve-wracking man
subscribe i will get this
okay there you go that's pretty good
who's who came up with this recipe let
me let me get this out of my system too
a little little and quietly observing
from the back
perfect it's a wiggly dude it's so
wiggly
could i like angle it like a little bit
is that cool and they don't fall in
that's my finger oh my god
oh my god i'm intimidating oh my
oh god god
you almost got it oh hey
salad a salad
oh
they're going right through
oh
the creepy watermelon monster showed up
i did not exactly
understand that this is what i signed up
for today
there we go
dude he's not missing wow
[Applause]
all right dude do you ever need any of
that
jacket or mask or anything can i can i
toss a banana and then you try to slice
[Music]
i hope it's not too thin and flimsy what
timing
you'll get a close-up shot in case this
gets destroyed it's gonna get destroyed
take it to get a close-up shot then
sweet
here let's do a close range test
that felt so solid dude
that's gonna backfire that's gonna like
that's gonna hook into it and swing
around hit you in the lip
you're scared i know it's okay it's
fierce and
natural holding the card
[Music]
it backfired and caught you just like
what rin said reddit was right the whole
time
[Music]
i wanted to roll on that oh
oh yeah you want to try that again do
that again were you really not rolling
no
no wait are you serious
are you serious go ahead and do that
again
[Applause]
and this is exactly how i designed it to
work this is
this is my plan finally coming together
dude
you did it go check out nick's channel
he does some great stuff thank you very
much for taking your time today and show
us some stuff
[Music]
you